[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر براكي
احييكم كل عام وانتم بالف خير هذه هي
العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل زواياه ومن
جميع جوانبه
النقد الدولي يصدم العالم بتوقعات متشائمه
للاقتصاد العالميه
في ايران النظام يسوق لاصلاح النظام دون
اصلاحين وممثل المرشد ينتقد صمتا المقربين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من السجن الى الرئاسه الولاده سيلفا يتسلم
مهامه لرئاسه البرازيل وسط تهديدات انصار
بورسونارو
كوره
امام القضاء لعدم سداد ايجار مكاتبها
وماسك اول شخص يخسر 200 مليار دولار في
التاريخ
لم تمضي 24 ساعه على دخول العالم عامه
الجديد 20 30
وهو عام كان حمل امنيه امنيات كبيره يعني
يحمل استقرارا سياسيا واقتصاديا حتى خرج
صندوق النقد الدولي لتوقعات متشائمه
الاقتصاد العالمي صندوق النقد توقع ان
يشهد الاقتصاد العالمي في الربع الثالث من
العام 23 23 ركودا مضيفا ان عام 20 23
سيكون صعبا على معظم الاقتصادات العالميه
من العالم الى اوروبا والتوقعات تشير هناك
الى ان نصف الاقتصادات الاوروبيه سيدخل في
ركود كما تتوقع صندوق النقد دخول ثلث
الاقتصاد العالمي في ركود خلال 20 23
وربما تنطبق مقوله اذا عطست الصين تاثر
العالم
في الصين يحمل انباء سيئه للاقتصاد
العالمي على المدى الق بحسب صندوق النقد
ايضا
[موسيقى]
من القاهره دكتور فخري الفقيه المساعد
السابق للمدير التنفيذي لصندوق النقد
الدولي اهلا بكم معنا دكتور في الشق الاول
سنتناول التوقعات الاقتصاديه هذه هو في
الشق الثاني معكم سنعود الى بعض الاسباب
خاصه ارهاصات 20 22 عندما نتحدث عن
التوقعات بناء على تصريحات سيده جورجيا
همم ما الذي يمكن ان نستشرفه اكثر على
صعيد حجم التاثر ماذا يعني الركوب تحديدا
وكيف سيؤثر على عالمنا العربي معك دكتور
اهلا بك تحياتي لك والاستاده المشاهدين
فيما تعلق بتصريحات السيده كريستالينا
جورجينا وهي مدير عام صندوق النقد الدولي
هي توقعات يعني التوجيهيه وتنبيهيه لكنها
صادمه بالنسبه لصناع القرار سواء كانوا
بنوك مركزيه عالميه وحكومات اللي هي
حكومات 190 دوله اعضاء في صندوق النقد
الدولي لانه عامل 23
سيستمر طبعا الوضع همم التشامي من حيث
معدلات النمو في الناتج المحلي او الناتج
العالمي همم كما توقعه في افاق الاقتصاد
العالمي تقرير صدر في اكتوبر بانه هيكون
اثنين وسبعه من 10 على مستوى العالم
معدلات النمو هبوطا من ثلاثه واثنين من 10
وايضا هبوطا من 6% اذا هو اا معدل ان هو
انخفض من سنه 21 الى او 22 الى 23
هينخفض من 6% الى 2.7 وقدم ينخفض وقد
ينخفض اكثر من ذلك الى 2% وده معناها انه
هناك دول في هذه الحاله المعدلات النمو
فيها قد تكون سالبه يعني اقل من الركود او
انكماشيه بالسالب معدلات نمو يعني ثلث دول
العالم ال 190 دوله اعضاء في الصندوق
ثلثهم في هذه الحلقه طيب تاثير العمل على
الناس على المواطنين خاصه في بعض عالمنا
العربي دكتور فخري لو سمحت لانه يتاثر
طبعا
في الدول العربيه نجد انه الدول العربيه
يعني في سنه 23 هناك توقعات بانه معدلات
النمو في الدول العربيه يعني هتكون موجبه
وليست سالبه وفي حدود الاربعه في المئه
على مستوى الدول العربيه لكن هناك دول سوف
تحقق معدلات النمو اعلى من ذلك وهناك دول
سوف ينخفض فيها معدل النمو عن 4% خلاصه
الامر انه لن يكون هناك ركود في الدول
العربيه ولكن يعني مهمه الدول العربيه
والبنوك المركزيه انها تكافح وتكسر حده
التضخم او قمه التضخم في هذه الحاله لذلك
الفتره القادمه سوف يكون هناك تشدد نقدي
من قبل البنوك المركزيه العربيه
صعبه دكتور يعني بعيدا عن دول النفطيه
والخارجيه
بالتاكيد طبعا ما ننساش ان هناك دول يعني
ممكن نقسم الدول العربيه الى الدول بترولي
وفي هذه الحلقه 23 انه الاسعار البترول
والغاز هتبدا يعني
تنخفض قليلا من ثمن معدلات النمو في الدول
الخليج سوفت يعني يظل الفائض موجود ولكن
معدلات النمو سوف تكون اقل من سنه 22 ان
هناك دول مستورده للبترول منها مصر في هذه
الحاله بنجد انخفاض اسعار البرميل البترول
يؤدي الى ارتفاع معدل النمو في مصر 4.4
واما الدول التي تعاني من توترات سياسيه
وباقي الدول العربيه نجد انه في دول عربيه
زي السودان واليمن وليبيا وسوريا الى اخره
في هذه الحاله هتعاني المعاناه شديده وقد
يؤدي الى انخفاضات معدل النمو قد يقترب من
السفر او الركود في هذه الحاله ولذلك
عندما ناخذ الدول العربيه مجتمعه انه
معدلات انه سوف يقوم موجبه بعض الدول
العربيه
سوف تعاني معانا شديده التي بها تعطورات
جيو سياسيه كما اشارنا في الدول التي
مازالت تعاني من تداعيات ثورات الربيع
العربي حتى الان لم تخرج من هذه
الازمه الكبيره حتى الان من سنه
على الاقل بنسبه الى بعض دول العالم
العربي ولكن النظره التشاؤميه الاقتصاد
العالمي ككل هي التي نتابع فيها معك انت
كرامتها بالبقاء معنا دكتور فالنظره
التشاؤميه للاقتصاد العالمي حملتها صدمات
العامه 2022 سلسله
ماقدت توقعات السابقه بان 20 22 سيكون
عاما من الازدهار الارتفاع الحاد في
الاسعار زياده معدلات الفائده الاحترار
المناخي ازمه الطاقه الخانقه والحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كلها ازمات تنذر
بعام من قاتم في 20 23
المؤرخ ادم توز اطلق على 20 22 تعبي يلخص
ما حدث عام متعدد الازمات متحدثا عن صدمات
متباينه تتفاعل معا لتجعل الوضع العام في
غايه الصعوبه صدمت بدات وتزايدت منذ بدايه
القرن مع الازمه الماليه عام 2008 وازمه
ديون السياديه ووباء كوفد نايتين وازمه
الطاقه لم يشهد وضع بهذا القدر من التعقيد
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وفقراء مشهد
اكده بن مائي رئيس قسم تحليل الاقتصاد
الكلي في اقصر ايكونوميكس في مقابله مع
العربيه اوضح فيها اسباب النظر التشاؤميه
للاقتصاد العالمي
توقعاتنا في اكسفورد ايكونوميكس اسوا من
الاراء السائده بشان نمو الاقتصاد العالمي
السنه القادمه نحن نتوقع ضعفا اكبر وركودا
اسوا من توقعات الاخرين لكن اذا نظرنا الى
التجارب التاريخيه هذا الركود سيكون
محدودا وسيكون اصغر من متوسط الفترات
السابقه في التاريخ
التضخم عنوان اخر لازمه مستمره فبعد سنوات
من التضخم الضعيف او حتى المستقر الا ان
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا والارتفاع
الحاد في اسعار الطاقه بدل الوضع سجل
التضخم مستويات غير مسبوقه منذ سبعينات
والثمانينات دافعا ملايين العائلات في
الدول الناميه الى الفقر ومهددا الاسر في
الدول الفقيره بمزيد من البؤس غير انه بدا
يتباطئ الى 10% في منطقه اليورو في نوفمبر
وسته في المئه في الولايات المتحده في
اكتوبر ويمكن ان يتراجع التضخم في الدول
المتطوره والناشئه الكبرى من مجموعه
العشرين في 20 23
24 بحسب منظمه التعاون والتنميه في
الميدان الاقتصاديه الا ان رئيس قسم تحليل
الاقتصاد الكلي في اوكسفورد لديه رايق
واو ويلي هناك
تضخم العالي الذي يضغط على استهلاك الاسر
والدخل الحقيقي ويؤدي الى تقليل الانفاق
اضافه الى سياسات تشديد الفائده التي
شاهدناها على مدار السنه وهذا يحتاج وقتا
ليتجسد في الاقتصاد بشكل حقيقي
من القاهره
لصندوق النقد الدولي دكتور اهلا بك معنا
مجددا يعني كنا قلنا انه سنتحدث الان عن
ابرز الاسباب التي ستؤدي الى الركود الذي
تم توقعه من قبل صندوق النقد الدولي خاصه
في 20 22 ما ابرز ذلك
صدقت القول سيدي في انه في هذه الحاله هذه
الالفيه الثالثه بدات فعلا تتسم به او
تتميز او يعني متعدده الازمات والصدمات
سواء كان احداث 11 سبتمبر في 2001 مرورا
بغزه الولايات المتحده للعراق و افغانستان
الى الازمه الماليه العالميه في
07/08/2017 الى ثورات الربيع العربي ثم
اسواق الناشئه في سنه 18 ثم قرون في سنه
20 ثم الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه كلها
ازمات وعلى ذلك ان في هذه الحلقه الازمه
الخليقه الحاليه مع ارتفاعات معدلات تضخم
نتيجه ان سلاسل الامدادات تاثرت وتعطلت
اهم سلسلتين من سلاسل الامداد الى جانب
ثلاث الامداد اخرى تعطلت عندنا روسيا
اوكرانيا يعني اكبر منتج للبترول والغاز
همم سلسله مهمه جدا في الطاقه وايضا
الحبوب واخرانيه ايضا الحبوب والزيوت
والاسمده كل دي ادت حطوا هذه وتحول هذه
سلاسل الامداد من تايوان في رقائق
الكترونيه من تايوان والصين الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اذا سلاسل الامداد يعني
بيحصل يحدث لها نوع من اعاده الهيكله وده
ادى الى ارتفاعات معدل التضخم كسر معدلات
تضخم لابد من التشدد النقدي والتشدد نقدي
من قبل معظم البنوك المركزيه الرئيسيه
العالميه
ولذلك رفع سعر الفائده في الفتره خلال ال
10 اشهر الماضيه ادى الى نوع من التراجع
وطباطه معدلات النمو على المستوى العالم
وحتى لا يصل المعدل التضخم لانه وجود
التضخم معناها انه يؤدي الى التوترات
اجتماعيه وهذا امر غير مرغوب ولذلك التشدد
النقدي في رفع السائل فائده يؤدي الى الى
تباته في معدلات النمو من يجد انه بالفعل
الولايات المتحده ودول اوروبا برفع سعر
الفائده
ادى الى
قمه معدل التضخم في هذه الحاله باستمرار
التوتر الجيوسي سياسي الموجود في بين
روسيا واوكرانيا ومستمر ولا نعلم متى
سينتهي في هذه الحياه من ضمن العوامل التي
تؤدي الى كثير من التباطؤ وايضا تؤدي الى
الدول الفقيره في حاله عدم اليقين على اقل
تقدير يعني دكتور كمساعده همم مدير
التنفيذي لصندوق النقد الدولي دكتور
اعذرني على النقاطعه للاستفاده من وجودك
معنا همم بحكم منصبك السابق ما هي
الاجراءات التي تعتقد بانه يجب اتخاذها
حاليا او تم التقصير في اتخاذها حتى الان
همم يتم هذه الاسود في العام المقبل في
هذا العام
يعني بكل بساطه انه طالما انه يعني القضيه
قضيه ارتفاع معدلات المخاطر اللي بيواجهها
اختصار العالم من ضمن يعني نتيجه هذه
الصدمات والازمات المستمر من سنه 2001 حتى
الان بنها يعني الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
يترتب على ذلك انه صانعي القرار البنوك
المركزيه العالميه محافظيها وايضا رؤساء
الحكومات في هذه الحاله واعضاء الحكومات
لل 190 دوله في يذهب لابد انه يستخدمه
ادوات التحول
واداره المخاطب الدوله التي يعني ده مهمه
صندوق النقد الدولي انه يعني يعطي لها
ادوات التحوت الكافيه من خلال يعني التحوت
تجاه ارتفاع الطاقه اسعار الطاقه تحول ضد
ارتفاع اسعار الحبوب فدوات التحوض اصبح
النهارده على اقتصاد العالم ان يتحول من
اقتصاد السوق من اقتصاد راس مالي الى
الاقتصاد السوق وده الحالي يتحول الاقتصاد
السوق يعني في طريقته نجد انه في بدايه
ظهور ما يسمى باقتصادات اداره المخاطر
العالميه او من نسميها اريسك مان ايقانافس
ولذلك ده مهم للغايه ان كل دوله لابد ان
تتحول عندنا في مصر في هذه الحاله مرونه
سعر الصرف الان لن يؤخذ الدولار كمؤشر
ولكن سوف يقوم البنك المركزي المصري بعمل
يعني سله من العملات من الاضافه الى الذهب
كسله في ناخوتها في مؤشر
لتحديد قيمه سعر صرف الجنيه المصري اذا
ارتفعت السله في هذه الحاله ينخفض قيمه
الجنيه المصري والعكس صحيح اذا خفض السله
هذه السله والمؤشر والمقاومه من سلم من
العملات والذهب اذا انخفض يرتفع قيمه
الجيش المصري اذا التغير
التغيرات في السله غير لما ناخذ الدولار
احنا مش مرتبطين بالدولار غير مرتبطين
بالدولار ولكن يؤخذ الدولار في مصر كمؤشر
اما الدول الخليج في هذه الحلقه تاخذ
الدولار تربه عملتها بالدولار يعني الست
دول عربيه خمسه منهم بيربطوا عملتهم
بالدولار اذا ارتفعت الدولار يرت- ترتفع
عملاتهم اذا منخفضه بالدوار انخفض اذا ما
رفع سعر الفائده في الولايات المتحده من
خلال لابد رفع سعر الفائده على العملات
الدول العربيه المرتبطه بالدولار ما عدا
طبعا الكويت مرتبط بسله من العملات في هذه
الحاله لكن الربط فيها زحله بالنسبه لمصر
هي بتاخذ هذه السله كمؤشر حتى يكون سعر
الصرف الجنيه المصري في هذه الحاله تمام
ثابته شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه الشروحات
دكتور فخريه المساعد السابق للمدير
التنفيذي لصندوق النقد الدولي من القاهره
شكرا لوجودك معنا تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
الى البرازيل وحفل تنصيب لولاد سيلفا
رئيسا للبرازيل وهذه الحشود المؤلفه التي
تحضر حفل التنصيب بعدما ادى الرئيس اليسرى
لويس ايناسيو لدى سيلفا اليمين رئيسا
للبرازيل اليوم وذلك
البرازيلي ليبدا فتره الثالثه
لولايتها اذن الفتره الثالثه التي يحكم
فيها رغم السجن كان لولا دا سيلفا قد تفوق
او فاز على ياء بوسونارو في انتخابات
اكتوبر الماضي كما اا نذكر وكان حكم
البرازيل لفتين لرئاسيتين وهذه الفتره
الثالثه بدات الان بين عامي 2003 و و10
كان هناك العديد من تحديدات انصار فول
سونانارو بارتيكا باعمال وصفت باعمال
العنف فيما همم اتخذت اجراءات امنيه مشدده
جدا في العاصمه تزامنا مع هذه الاحتفالات
التي تعقب اداء اليمين في الكونغرس
العاصمه البرازيليه يسودها التوتر طبعا
ومن المفترض ان يغادر رولا دا سيلفا
الكونجرس حيث ادى اليمين مع نائبه ايضا
الى همم هذا الى ساحه هذا القصر في
العاصمه البرازيليه
للمشاركه في هذه الاحتفالات نحن نتحدث عن
قصر
طلعنالتو الشهير في العاصمه برازيليه همم
وهو من المتوجهه من المتوقع ان يتوجه اليه
لولا ده سيلفا لوضع الوشاح الرئاسي كما هو
متعار عليه هناك امام هذا الحشد من عشرات
الالاف من البرازيليين الذين همم يحتشدون
هناك طبعا الشرطه البرازيليه كانت القت
القبض اليوم على رجل بحوزته عبوه ناسفه
وسكين في اثناء محاولته دخوله هذه الساحات
التي امامكم والتي تقام فيها مراسم
التنصيب نذكر بان لولاد سيلفا طبعا هو
يسري وتعهد في خطابه اليوم بالانحياز الى
الفقراء وبتحسين حياه البرازيليين الفقراء
وبالعمل على مكافحه العنصريه والعمل على
المساواه بين الجنسين
ومكافحه التصحر في الامازون همم خلفا
لسلفه نعود بعد قليل لمتابعه هذا الحشد
الهائل الذي يتابع تنصيب
للبرازيل
[موسيقى]
انتهى عام وبدا اخر والاحتجاجات في ايران
مستمره حاولت ايران احتوائها مره
ومقاومتها مرات فجر فقد قتل النظام
الايراني مهساين ليفجر بعد ذلك احتجاجات
عامه المدن الايرانيه وفي خطوه لاحتواء
غضب الشارع حلت ايران شرطه الاخلاق لكن
اليوم ربما عادت لتستاني فا نشاطها من
جديد بعد انتشار اخبار عن عوده شرطه
الاخلاق الى شوارع ايران وكاله انباء فارس
اكدت الخبر نقلا عن مسؤول كبير في الشرطه
عبر عوده الرسائل النصيه التي تتعلق
بالحجاب الالزاميه لاصحاب السيارات بدات
ايران ايضا العام الجديد بمزيد من الترهيب
عبر الاعدام اذا اصدرت محكمه ايرانيه في
مدينه نصر بمقاطعه مازن داران بايران
الحكم على شيان محمدي بالاعدام
مناسبه
الشعبيه في ايران ولم توقفها او ترهبها
على ما يبدو اله القمع التي يسلطها النظام
اعلى رقابهم لكن اصواتا مؤثره كرئيس
البرلمان والقائد السابق للحرس الثوري
محمد باقر قالباظ بدا يتحدثان عن ضروره
اصلاح نظام الحكم في البلاد لكنه اصلاح
يخلو من رجال الاصلاح او قاده الاصلاح
او جلهم اما في السجون او تحت الاقامه
الجبريه قالب دعا الى اعطاء القضايا
الاقتصاديه اولويه وقال خلال جلسه علانيه
في البرلمان انه يجب حل مشاكل الشعب
واتخاذ القرارات في الوقت المناسب تصريحات
تذكر باخرى نادره ادلى بها قالباس واعتبر
حينها بل اعترف بارتكاب اخطاء في اداره
البلاد داعيا لاصلاحي اليه الحكم واكد
خلال مقابله تلفزيونيه ان حكومه الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي فشلت في تحسين الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه الاي العنييين في ظل
تراجع القدره الشرائيه وانهيار العمله
لكن كلام قالباف تصفه المعارضه بانه ذر
للرمادي في العيون فلا اصلاح يتم بحكومه
متشدده كحكومه رئيس والاهم من دون اصلاحين
لكن اين هم هؤلاء ابرزهم الرئيس الاسبق
محمد خاتمي المبعد عن المشهد السياسي في
البلاد بامر من المرشد الايراني
رئيسا لم يكن الرجلان على الوفاق وبالطبع
لن ننسى قاده الثوره الخضراء في ايران عام
2009 مير حسين موسوي ومهديك الروبي وهم
الخاضعان للاقامه الجبريه منذ ذلك الوقت
مصطفى تازادا مستشار الرئيس الاسبق محمد
خاتمي والذي اعتقل من 2009 حتى 2016
لتاييد الثوره الخضراء ثم اعيد اعتقاله في
يوليو 20 22 بتهمه تقويم امن الدوله
عائله الرئيس الاسبق علي اكبر هاشمي
رفسنجاني مهدي ومحسن مع اختهم فائزه او
اختهما فائزه رفسنجاني التي اعتقلها
النظام في سبتمبر الماضي بتهمه التحريض
على الشغب اذا هي دعوه تبدو فارغات
المضمون تلك التي اطلقها طالباز بعدم وجود
كل هؤلاء
[موسيقى]
تحديث نظام الحكم في جميع المجالات ضروره
يجب وضعها على اجنده الدوله والان نعمل
على ايجاد توافق في الاراء بشان القرارات
الضروريه التي يجب اتخاذها في هذا التوقيت
كما اكدت من البدايه يجب ان تعطى الاولويه
للقضايا الاقتصاديه
اصلاحوا المنظومه الحاكمه يزداد صعوبه او
استحاله بطريقه عمل النظام الحالي وفق
المعارضه الايرانيه فهناك انهيار مخيف
للعمله مقابل الدولار اضف الى ذلك الازمات
الاجتماعيه الخانقه التي تفرضها هيكليه
النظام ثم ازماتها البرنامج النووي
والبرنامج الصاروخي جاءت الاحتجاجات لتفرض
نتيجه قمعه السلطات العنيف لها عقوبه
جديده من اوروبا والولايات المتحده وكندا
[موسيقى]
احتجاجات شعبيه متواصله منذ سبتمبر اخرها
تعليق لافته كبيره على جسر في حي ولي عصر
وسط طهران تدعو الى الانضمام للاحتجاجات
كتب عليها ايها المواطن انتفض لا
للاعدامات فيما شهدت اربع مدن هي جوان رود
وسندج وسميران واصفهان تظاهرات ضد السلطات
ردد المتظاهرون في خلالها شعارات الموت
لخامنائي والموت للديكتاتور وفي محافظه
اصفهان اعلن الحرس الثوري عن مقتل محسن
رضائي احد عناصر المسيج نتيجه اطلاق نار
من قبل مسلحين خلال اضطرابات شهدتها مدينه
سميران الواقعه على بعد 160 كلم عن مركز
المحافظه
[موسيقى]
اشكرك
حسب موقع هيرانا الذي يرصد قضايا حقوق
الانسان في ايران والذي وثق مقتل 508
اشخاص منذ سبتمبر الماضي بينهم 69 شخصا
دون ال 18 من العمره
كما وثق الموقع مقتل 66 من قوات الامن
خلال الاحتجاجات مع اعتقال اكثر من 18,000
شخص من بينهم
667 طالبا جامعيا كله اله القمع تلك لا
يبدو انها افلحت بقمع الايرانيين
المستمرين بالتظاهر في عموم البلاد
[موسيقى]
حبيبي بيبوس بويكا
سياسيه داخليه وازمات اقتصاديه طاحنه تبدي
ايران استعدادها لاحياء مفاوضات الاتفاق
النووي في الوقت ذاته صرح مسؤول امريكي
لموقع جاد ايران ان الساسه الايرانيين
قتلوا اي فرصه لعوده سريعه للاتفاق النووي
بعقبه وتلاشيف راسي تحقيق اختراق يسلمو
العام 2022 الايراني
التي شكلت ريهانا كبيرا على الخروج من عنق
زجاجه الازمه الاقتصاديه
حمل في هذا السياق مسؤوليه مراوحه
المفاوضات النوويه للسلطات الايرانيه وفق
موقع اجاده ايران مشيرا الى طهران قتلت
حظوظ العوده السريعه الى الاتفاق النووي
بسبب رفضها المتكرر للمقترحات المعروضه
عليها خلال العامين الماضيين لكن بالنسبه
الى المسؤولين الايرانيين فلديهم رؤيه
سياسيه مختلفه عبر عنها في اكثر من مناسبه
وزير الخارجيه حسين امير عبد الله الفرصه
سامحه لاتخاذ الخطوات النهائيه لاحياء
الاتفاق النووي لكنها لن تبقى كذلك للابد
لكن خلف تعثر في عده حقائق فرضتها عوامل
بعضها قديم واساسي وبعضها الاخر مستجد في
العوامل القديمه اصرار ايران على غلق ملف
التحقيق باثر اليورانيوم في عده مواقع
نوويه يقابله اصرار من الوكاله الدوليه
بمواصله التحقيق وانتظار اجوبه واضحه من
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه في العناصر
الجديده انزلاق ايران او تورطها في تسليح
روسيا بالمسيرات في حربها على اوكرانيا
ايضا برز موقف امريكي جديد نقل الاولويه
من مفاوضات فيينا الى احتجاجات ايران
واشنطن ستركز جهودها على امدادات الاسلحه
الايرانيه الى روسيا وعلى دعم المتظاهرين
بدلا من التركيز على المحادثات النوويه
المعطله التي لا نعرفها فائدتها
حاله عدم يقين سياسي تترافق مع تازه من
اقتصادي ضاغط وتدفع الاحتجاجات والاضرابات
الى التحول الى مشهد دائم في المدن
الايرانيه طالب تبدا بشعارات الحريه
والانتفاضه على النظام وتمر بالتضخم
والوظائف والاجور كالملف النووي تبقى
معلقه بلا اجابات او معالجات مستدامه
نحن مقوره معكم في العربيه 360 نتابع فيها
ايضا بعد الفاصل بعد ضبط شبكه تهريب نقطه
تضم ومسؤولين رئيس المحكمه الاتحاديه
العراقيه يحملوا السياسيين مسؤوليه عدم
مكافحه الفساد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نلتقي مباشره الى
العاصمه البرازيليه البرازيليه مع حفل
تنصيب لولا دا سيلفا رئيسا للبرازيل اعتقد
انه وصل هذه الصوره اذا كان بامكاني ان
ارى الشاشه بشكل اكبر لكي تمكن من رؤيه
الصوره اذا خرج من الكونغرس الان مع نائبه
ومن المفترض ان يتوجهها بعد قليل واضح انه
في تاخير قليلا بناء على الجدول المعلن
اييه من قبل
القيمين على الحفل اذا الناس
همم
الكونجرس مع نائبه وعدد من المسؤولين
البرازيليين وسيتوجه الى مكان الاحتفال
طبعا كانت تعهد قبل قليل باعاده بناء
البلاد مع الشعب البرازيلي كما قال ولكن
هناك الكثير من التحديات بدون شكل التي
تواجه همم حكمه تحدي اقتصادي بشكل اساسي
في هذا البلد الذي يعاني من ركود
اضافه الى انهاء حاله انقسام والشرخ
الكبير الذي حدث على اثر الخلاف مع بول
سونارو الرئيس السابق الذي توجه الى
فلوريدا بالمناسبه يوم الجمعه لكي لا يضطر
الى تسليم لولا ده سيلفا الوشاح بنفسه
لمنافسه وهو لم يعترف بفوزه حتى الان على
كل حال كان انصار بون سونار وقد نظم
احتجاجات لما يصفونه بالسرقه الانتخابات
داعينا الى انقلاب عسكري لمنع عوده الولاد
سيلفا كل ذلك الان همم يعني يذهب هباءا مع
كل هذه الاجراءات اجراءات التنصيب همم
اذا هناك همم المزيد من الصور والفيديوهات
التي سنتابعها لوصوله بعد قليل الى ساحه
الاحتفال حيث القصر قصر
حيث يضع الوشاح الرئاسي امام الحشد الذي
يتجمع هناك نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي
نقعد بعد قليل الى هذه الصور في العراق
قال رئيس المحكمه الاتحاديه العليا جاسم
عبود انا نقل المرجعيه المفوضيه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات الى الجهات السياسيه
يفقدها الاستقلاليه لافيا ان تكون المحكمه
تقدمت باي مقترح بشان تعديل الدستور واشار
عبود الى ان الفساد اعق بناء الدوله وانه
لم ينتهي ما لم تتوفرني الحقيقيه لدى
السياسيه
هذا واعلن جهاز الامن الوطني في العراق
القاء القبض على 94 شخصا بينهم ضباط كبار
في وزاره الداخليه العراقيه وتجار كانوا
متورطين في قضيه تهريب النفط ومشتقاته
بكميات تقدر بنحو 75 مليون لتر شهريا
لجنه التحقيق العراقي بما وصف بفضيحه سرقه
ضباط للنفط الخام في محافظه البصره تكشف
عن اليات وطرق عمليات التهريب وبيع النفط
المسروق قضيه النفط تورط فيها تسعه ضباط
في وزاره الداخليه
تتراوح رتبهم بين لواء رائد شاركوا شبكه
واسعه لسرقه النفط الخام في محافظه البصره
الجنوبيه جهاز الامن العراقي اطلع لجنه
التحقيق على معلومات استخباراتيه جزئيه
بشان قضيه التهريب قالت ان حلولا الليل
كان شرطا لاتمام عمليات السرقه وبشكل يومي
والدوره بالضباط يعتمد على حمايه المهربين
اثناء احداثهم ثغرات بالخطوط الناقله ثم
مجدي انابيب منها الى اماكن تحميل النفط
عبر شاحنات تقوم بدورها بتهريبه الى اقليم
كردستان الشمالي ومنه الى سوريا ودول اخرى
حيث يتم بيعه يحصل باطو بالمقابل على نحو
320.000$ حصيله ثغره انبوب واحد وتقدر
كميات المهربه يوميا من خمسه الى سبعه
صهاريج بسعه 50,000 لتر للخلق الواحد فيما
يقدر عدد الصهاريج المهربه من 40 الى 50
صهريجا بمعدل 75 مليون لتر شهريا اللافت
ان عمليات سرقه وبيع النفط لا تقتصر على
محافظه البصره بل ومنذ سنوات تتردد
معلومات في تقارير محليه عن عمليات سرقه
وتهريب للنفط ومشتقاته في معظم المحافظات
العراقيه التي يتوفر بها الذهب الاسود
معنى الان من بغداد المستشار سابق في
وزاره الدفاع العراقيه مع الجمهوري اهلا
بك معنا سيد معا اييي يعني كان كل ذلك
يحصل تحت جنح الليل ما الذي ادى الى اماطه
اللثام الان عن هذه الحقائق المؤسفه
كل عام وانتم بخير
بصراحه هذه الحالات موجوده
[موسيقى]
همم بصراحه همم تتسرب كثير من المعلومات
عبر المتابعه الاستخباراتيه من الاجهزه
الامنيه ومن المخابرات
وبالتالي همم جمع تحقيق في معرفه همم
حيثيات هذه الجريمه همم طبعا هناك اشارات
كثيره منذ منذ فتره طويله وما تحدث به
بالقضاء لان هناك غطاء سياسي عندما اشار
الى الفساد او الى التدخل في المفوضيه هذه
واضحه جدا ان المنظومه السياسيه فيها فساد
كبير فيها هنا همم البنيه السياسيه
والحكوميه فيها فساد منذ عقدين من الزمن
بمعنى انها كلها متورطه بمثل هذه العمليات
والا اين الترتبيه اين كانت الوزارات
المعنيه اين كان المسؤولون عندما كانوا
هؤلاء الضباط اضافه الى مسؤولين اخرين
وقيادات في الدوله تعمل على هذا النهب
والسرقه من امام قطن
واستاد اعلن رسميا في اكثر من مره ان هناك
اكثر من 300 مليار ليس مليار مليار دولار
حجم المفقودات والسرقات في همم العراق منذ
2003 حتى اللحظه هذه لم يسرقها مواطن بسيط
ولم يسرقها عامل بسيط انما القدس سياسيه
الاحسان
عندما يسرق همم
نعم نعم ولذلك هي منظومه كما ذكرت تعمل
علل وفق مصالح مشتركه حتى ال ال المحاسسه
دخل في دخلت في الفساد وكله وزاره وكله
حزب لديه ما يستفيد منه من وزارته ومن
المناطق نفوذه كما حصل في هذا هذه واحده
استاذ طاهر هذه واحده من حالات الفساد
التي تم اكتشافها كما حدث قبل شهرين
تقريبا همم سرقه سميه بسرقه القرن يعني
ايضا موضوع السارق نور زهير وما خلفه لا
يمكن ان يمكن لشخص واحد في العالم ان يسرق
مليارات الدولارات بهذه السهوله اذا هناك
غطاء سياسي
هو في الواقع هل سيتوسع هذا الملف ليشمل
الجميع او على الاقل على الاقل يوقف
الجميع عن هذا النهب المستمر لانه المشكله
لا تكون هناك محاسبه والمشكله الاكبر ان
تتوقف المحاسبه على عدد معين على حفنه من
الاشخاص فقط كبش فداء
الان الاقتراب من عش الدبابير
الاقتراب من عش الدبابير يجب ان يقتحم عش
الدباديب هذه
الجرائم اعلنت على الملا واخذ القضاء فيها
تحقيقا ولذلك صدر هذا التصريح من القضاء
لا يمكن تغطياتها بعد هذه المعلومات التي
اعلنت على المواطن العراقي لم يعد يقوى
على الانتظار يعني هو الاول يعني على كلام
القضاء هذا تحول عليه
القضاء القضاء ليس دائره تنفيذيه انما فقط
يصدر الاحكام لم التعويل على الحكومه يجب
ان تكون الاراده السياسيه لان لا يمكن
للقاضي ان ينفذ اوامر القبض او يعتقل
الوزير انما يصدر احكاما بهذا ولكن
الحكومه هنا هل يكون في مستوى المسؤوليه
وتستطيع ان تلقي القبض او تضع خلف القضبان
هؤلاء المجرمين وان كانوا يعملوا صفات
كبيره هذه المعدل الشارع يترقب لا يمكن
الاستهانه بعد الان لان المواطن لم يعد
ينتظر لا يمكن ان تنط لي عليه لعبه من هنا
وهناك باننا سوف نضرب بيد من حديد او سوف
نحاسبه فاسدين او سوف نحصر السلاح بيد
الدوله الان المواطن ينتظر يوما بعد يوم
لكي يرى ويشاهد مخرجات ما يتقدمت به
الحكومه من برنامج حكومي من
سقف الامنيات التي طرحتها على المواطن
وبدات ينتظر
انا اعتقد ان الحكومه على المحك هنا اما
ان تقدم على ما يلبي رغبه المواطن واما
ستلقى نفس المصير الذي كانت عليه حكومه
السابقه هي المواطن سيلجا الى الشارع
ويمارس دوره ضد منها
يجب ان نذهب الى البرازيل مجددا معنى
الجمهوريه المستشار السابق في وزاره
الدفاع العراقيه من بغداد تحياتي اليك
متابعه هذه الصور اذا لموكب همم لولا ده
سيلفا الرئيس البرازيلي همم القديم الجديد
اذا صح التعبير يحكم لولايه الثالثه الان
بعد ولايتين وهو يحيي انصاره في هذا
الموكب في السياره المكشوفه التي يستقلها
مع عدد من مسؤولين همم حكمها وطبعا الامن
واضح انه مشدد جدا الامن البرازيلي يوافق
يرافق السياره الرئاسيه الموكب الرئاسي عن
يمينه وعن يساره ومن خلفه بطبيعه الحال
بالتزامن معه وجود الالاف من المناصرين
المؤيدين
وهو الذي يتوجه الان الى قصر
امام مؤيديها الذين راينا صورهم قبل قليل
في الساحه ساحه القصر
الصوره لهم كذلك لولاده سيلفا دو 77 عاما
كان تغلب على بوتسونارو في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الماضيه همم يعني بفارق ضئيل في
الواقع رغم انه كان عاما ونصف عام في
السجن بتهم فساد اسقطت لاحقا همم هو رئيس
ينتمي لحزب العمال وكان يعني يحسب له ما
يوصف باخراج الملايين من البرازيليين من
تحت خط الفقر خلال همم ما يعرف بتفرق
اسعار السلع الاوليه التي دعمت الاقتصاد
صوره همم
للموكب الرئاسي البرازيلي وهو يتوجه من
الكونغرس الى ساحه الاحتفال ساحه التوشيح
عندما سيضع
في ساحه قصر
الوشاح الرئاسي امام مؤيدي سونار وسلف
وكان غادر الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يوم الجمعه لكي لا يضطر لتسليم الوشاح
لمنافسه طبعا انصار بون سونار وغاضبون
وكانوا يهددون
وهناك تحذيرات من اعمال عنف طبعا كان
هاملتون مراو وهو الرئيس السابق بالانابه
الذي كان نائبا لبوسونارو انتقد الرئيس
السابق لما سماه فشله في قياده البلاد
والسماح بتاجيج المشاعر المناهضه
للديمقراطيه كما سماها بعد هزيمته في
الانتخابات في اكتوبر الماضي همم قال
الزعماء همم كان من المفترض ان يطمئن
ويوحد الامه ولكنهم همم سمحوا بخلق مناخ
من الفوضى والتفكر الاجتماعي قد تعود الى
هذه الصور لاحقا
[موسيقى]
الازمات تلاحق شركه تويتر قضائيا وتلاحق
مالكها الجديد الى الماسك ماديا بخسائر
تاريخيه لم تعرفها البشريه من قبل لشخص
واحد البدايه بالشركه نفسها اي تويتر اذ
تواجه دعوى قضائيه لتخلفها عن سداد ايجار
مكتب لها في مدينه سان فرانسيسكو باكثر من
135,000 دولار الدعوه رفعتها شركه
كولومبيريت الملكه للمساحه المكتبيه
المؤجره لشركه تويتر في منتصف الشهر
الماضي رغم اهمال الشركه الملكه لتويتر
خمسه ايام لدفع المبلغ الا ان تويتر لم
تقوم بسدادته مشكله اخرى تواجهها تويتر
كذلك او ازمه اخرى بالاضافه الى التخلف عن
سداد ايجار مكاتبها الرئيسه بالاضافه الى
المكاتب الاقليميه وهي اموال مستحقه لم
تدفعها تويتر لتاجيرها رحلتي طياره
[موسيقى]
الملياردير لهم مسكن استحوذ على موقع
تويتر مقابل 44 مليار دولار في صفقه
جابتها دعوه واتهامات وجدل واستقال المئات
من موظفيه في نوفمبر بينهم مهندسون
مسؤولون عن اصلاح الاخطاء ومنع انقطاع
الخدمه
بالكثير من الفوضى والمشكلات والهجمات
الشخصيه لكن تلك ليست اكبر مشكله الرجل
اصبح هائله ماسك اول شخص يخسر 200 مليار
دولار من صافي ثروته في التاريخ لكن كيف
حدثت هذه الانتكاسه له شهيد مصر
انخفاضا في ثروته الى 137 مليار دولار بعد
تهاوي اسهم شركه لصناعه السيارات
الكهربائيه تسلا في الاسابيع الاخيره بما
في ذلك الانخفاض بنسبه 11 بالمئه الثلاثاء
وفقا لمؤشر بلومبرج لاصحاب المليارات وهذا
انخفاض من ذره ثروته البالغه 340 مليار
دولار في رابع من نوفمبر من 20 21 وظل
اغنى شخص في العالم لنحوي عامين حتى
تجاوزه في ديسمبر برنار الملياردير
الفرنسي ورئيس مجلس اداره شركه الفي ام
اتش للسلع الفاخره
الويفيتون يعني كان نمو ثروه ايلان ماسك
مدفوعا بالاساس منحصته في تسلا بعدما
تجاوزت القيمه السوقيه للشركه تريليون
دولار للمره الاولى في اكتوبر لتنضمام الى
شركات التكنولوجيا العملاقه ابل
مايكروسوفت وامازون لكنها تتسلى على سوق
السيارات الكهربائيه باتت معرضه للخطر
مؤخرا ايديا الحق المنافسون بالركب رغم
محاولات الشركه طرحه اغراءات ضخمه
للمستهلكين الاهم صفقه شراء تويتر اثباع
ماسك الكثير من الاسهم في 20 22 للمساعده
في تغطيه صفقه تويتر لدرجه ان حصته في
تسلا لم تعد اكبر اصوله وفقا لمؤشر الثروه
الخاصه
[موسيقى]
ريان جديد لكن هذه المره في فيتنام حيث
افادت وسائل اعلام المحليه بان عمال
الانقاذ في فيتنام يعملون على انقاذ طفل
يبلغ من العمر 10 سنوات سقط في حفره
خرسانيه عمقها 35 مترا وعرضها 25سم فقط
ولول الى الطفل يحاول رجال الانقاذ انتشار
الطفل عبر انشاء حفره بعمق 35 مترا حول
الحفره الخرسانيه للوصول اليه في ما اظهر
الفيديو او اظهرت الفيديوهات دخل الاكسجين
للطفل عبر خرطوم صغير وهو لا يزال بحاله
قره الى الان
ساقول
[موسيقى]
نتمنى السلامه للطفل بشكل عاجل الى المجاز
الرياضيه الان في العربيه 360 مع زياد
عبيدات
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا طاهر واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
لحساب الجوله التاسعه 10 من الدوري
الانجليزي الممتاز لكره القدم تعادل
تشيلسي بهدف لكل منهما مع مضيفه
بهدف لكل منهما بهذه النتيجه رصيده الى 25
نقطه في المركز الثامن وبا فريق الاهداف
عن فلها مقابل 10,000ديقي ان كان في
المركز الثامن عشر
واصلت وسائل الاعلام العالميه تمامها
بصفقه انتقال اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى الدوري السعودي ونشر صحيفه
اديلي ميلا البريطانيه تقريرا عن احتفال
جماهير النصر بالصفقه في الدقيقه السابع
من لقاء النصر مع الخليج ضمن منافسات
الدوري السعودي
وكتبتها الصحيفه على الرغم من ان رونالدو
لم يصل بعد الى النادي لكنه مشجعين النصر
ليس بامكانهم الانتظار لرؤيه بطالهم
الجديد في الملعب
وشهد متجر ونادي النصر اقبالا كبيرا
للحصول على قميص رونالدو وذكر صحيفه
الاقتصاديه السعوديه ان المتجر باع اكثر
من خمسه الاف قميص يحمل الرقم سبعه وسم
رونالدو مقابل نحو 120$ بقيمه تصل الى
مليونين ريال بعدنا هذه جميع القمصان ومن
المنتظر ان يصل الى رونالدو الى الرياض
خلال الاسبوع الحالي لبدء مشواره مع فريق
النصر السعودي
فاذا المتسابق الاسباني كارلوس ساينز
بالمرحله الاولى من رالي ذكر المقام حاليا
في السعوديه للعام الرابع على التوالي
وتصدر ساينزا المرحله التي بدات وانتهت في
مخيم البحر في ينبع بمسافه وصلت الى 63 كم
وفي بقيه الفئات حل الارجنتيني مانويلا
اندخار في المركز الاول في فئه الاكواد
وتصدر الامريكيه ريكيه برابيك فئه
الدراجات الناريه بعد معاقبه الاستراليه
دانيال ساندر بسبب تجاوز السرعه
ذكاره حقيقه من اهم الفعاليات اللي احنا
نقيمها في المملكه العربيه السعوديه زي ما
انتم الان شاهدتم بانفسكم كيف كبروا العدد
المشاركين كل هالابطال وكل الفرق من انحاء
العالم تيجي عشان تحاول انها تنافس وتثبت
نفسها على ارض المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بانها قادر ان تخوض اصعب الراليات واكبر
الراليات واهميهم على الاطلاق وهو
والدتكار همم السعوديه اسماء اكبر اسماء
موجوده اهم الاسماء في عالم الرياضيات
موجوده في ارض حقيقه يعني تعطيل كثير
للراليات شاهدنا اا خلال الاربع سنين
الماضيه همم
مناطق جدا جميله مناطق جدا همم همم يعني
همم
مخصصه للراليات في التنوع الجغرافي ما
تلقى في اي بلد ولا اي مكان الا الحمد لله
بلد مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولا تاخذ يعني كلام يعني اسال المتسابقين
كيف يشوفوا المنافسه كيف شافه الحمد لله
الترتيبات التجهيزات اللي يقدمها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في جميع همم
المناسبات فهي بشهاده الجميع لله الحمد
افضل نسخ دكار على الاطلاق
اللي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه نشوف
السنه هذه انتقلنا في مناطق جديده همم
كانت البدايه من ينبع والنهايه هتكون في
في المنطقه الشرقيه في همم فيها الخبر
الحمد لله اليوم خلصنا المرحله بسلامه
طبعا ما كانت همم
[موسيقى]
اا ما كنا محظوظين همم اليوم همم ضعنا بعض
المناطق كانت شوي صعبه ولكن همم رجعنا في
نهايه المرحله بقوه وصار ترتيبنا السابع
اليوم هذه بدايه المرحله ان شاء الله
وبكره طبعا المراحل راح تكون اصعب واا
ونحاول نتقدم يوم بيوم ووو وان شاء الله
فالكم الفوز باذن الله
كشفت شقيقته
لا تعلم بنبا كره القدم العالميه ولم يتم
اخبارها بان ابنها قد توفى بسبب السرطان
وتتولى شقيقته بيليه رعايتها والدتها التي
بلغت فيها عام ولم يتم اخبارها بان ابنها
لاعبوا كره القدم شهير توفي بعد معاناه من
سرطان القولون وفتت تقاريرها صحفيه الى ان
جنازه بلاليه ستمر بقرب منزل والدته قبل
دفنه
من جانبه كرم الاتحاد البرازيلي لكره
القدم الاسوره بيليه بوضع ملصق ضخم خارجي
مقره كتب عليه ابدي باللغه البرتغاليه
[موسيقى]
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك طاهر
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك زياد صوره اليوم في العربيه 360
من احتفالات العالم بالعام الجديد 20 23
كل عام وانتم بالف خير مجددا نتابعها اذا
وفي تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 للرئيس
الاوكراني ايفرتون الذي صرح في تمنياته
للسنه الجديده بان يكون العام 20 23 عاما
مصري في الحرب ضد روسيا واضاف في رسالته
بالقول عن سعيد عن انتصارنا وذلك بعد 10
اشهر من الحرب في اوكرانيا
فيديو اليوم من مدينه سكاربرا البريطانيه
التي الغت عرض الالعاب الناريه ليله راس
السنه بسبب وصول حيوان الفضل الشبيه
بالفقمه الى ميناء المدينه خوفا من ان
تقلق الاصوات راحته المتحدث باسم مجلس
المدينه قال ان راحه حيوان الفضل اولويه
استنادا الى مشهوره مؤسسه متخصصه
[موسيقى]
شكرا على متابعتكم العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار
الساعه لا تنقطع